today we're going to talk about the first
symptom of a fatty liver and that is malaise
now what is malaise it's this general discomfort
uneasiness type feeling you're feeling like you're
coming down with something it's an absence of
feeling good and malaise is not very specific to
a certain part of the body it's kind of all over
it's kind of vague you're not sure where it is
and you feel a little bit of weakness
what's happening is your immune system is
activated there are cytokines which are certain
proteins that are activating the immune system
at a certain level not enough for an infection
but just enough to make you feel like you could
be coming down with something now malaise
is many times also associated with fatigue
but it's not fatigue but the first symptom that
occurs with a fatty liver is malaise with the
second symptom being more right shoulder pain
because the liver is on the right side and when
it starts swelling up it can put pressure into the
right side and cause discomfort on the right side
now there are other causes of malaise like an
infection or low blood sugar caffeine withdrawal
or the flu and of course like i said a fatty
liver once your way to know that you have fat and
liver is just by looking down and if you can't
see your feet because your gut is sticking out
you definitely have a fatty liver now in the past
i've created a lot of videos in the liver so i
put some links down below of the most important
ones with the exact diet that you should be on
if you have a liver problem and in a recent video
i talked about adding probiotics to your diet if
you have a fatty liver because that is going
to reduce the immune response and you'll start
feeling better right away but there's a lot more
that can be done so if you suspect a fatty liver
check out the links down below thanks for watching
before you go if you have a question about a
product or you're new to keto and you want to
know how to begin keto or you're on keto and
you need a debug because it's not going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to help you
this is just for the people in the us hopefully in
the future we'll be able to answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below
so you can call and get some help